greetings to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happened now is brought to you by
zip recruiter listen to me
are you hiring every business needs
great people and a better way to find
them is something better than posting
your job online and just praying for the
right people to see it alright cuz if
you're hiring zip recruiter is the way
to go
zip recruiter learns what you're looking
for identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job now do me a favor right now
today my listeners the Church of what's
happened now the family
you can try zip recruiter for free
that's free right now just go to zip
recruiting table slash church that zip
recruited comm slashed church and give
zip recruiter a try right now it's the
smartest way to hire zip recruiter comm
slash Church take that [ __ ]
muley that's all I'm saying whatever
that is at the end gets me design yeah
that's [ __ ] John Paul Jones on an
organ yeah yeah transmitters on it from
Martians and [ __ ] the Church of what's
happened now [ __ ] just a casual
conversation today my main man and
well-known [ __ ] everything AJ Benza
what he said hey uncle Joey we you know
[ __ ] kind of put the pieces together I
gotta go to Columbus Ohio all night nice
it's an air force town I think yeah that
clubs been there forever
yeah and people go there and no well
what are you gonna do in Ohio
I mean before the before the Cavaliers
were good think of a think of a Friday
night in Ohio
yeah a lot of this [ __ ] to do do you I
mean I thought Matt were you gonna
figure Canton is the capital gamblin oh
yeah yeah that's the Columbus has
chicken on Columbus is a college
oh okay yeah I didn't know I don't
travel like they know that oh that's
really okay when you travel when you
start to learn they're the demographics
of different cities and then you know
you've been on the road for a long time
when the demographic of that city
changes right so right let's say for
years you did Gotham well all of a
sudden the heart
club in this country is in the
Meatpacking this I lived there then next
thing you know you're in the Meatpacking
District where you wouldn't go to
different twenty years ago that's were
there that's where the restaurants are
now that's where the Highline Highline
is up there so tells it's so weird how
do you see the demographics of cities
change over the years in El Paso four
years it was the one side of town
sure party side then all sudden they
built up downtown that guy bought the
building he ain't a bag of dicks nobody
came to the club no more
I got a relocated so what was Austin
like 25 years ago must be quiet
yeah very you know it's weed when you
gonna ask somebody I spoke to the girl I
wanna give a shout out from the Santa
Hannah casino and then she was thinking
about Austin or Denver as the city to
move to her and I told her that most
cities right now that everybody's moving
there yeah like Atlanta was yeah 21
years ago like everybody's moving on
Austin and Austin's [ __ ] crowd yeah
right right
I still love lost him with all my heart
it was just there with Lee the food is
great welcome me I heard that the people
off the map but you've seen the growth
now it doesn't take seven minutes to get
to the comedy club no more it takes 15
the traffic is double you know yeah I
haven't been to Houston in a while but
after Katrina to change out of the city
listen that changed the geography of
America and not only just because of
what happened to to New Orleans but
whether this place people went it
changed economies it changed the way
people lived restaurant me think of
everything that changed suddenly you got
hundreds of people are displaced from
Louisiana who are used to that food used
to that music
I'm sure places and those other regions
took that on you know I can't just with
the music with the Houston yeah Houston
takes place it's funny when I went to
Albuquerque this last weekend I went to
Jackson wink Jim's only give them a
shout out the best gym in the country
firemen that John Jones how many homes
that great Stratego they they have set
up a strategy for a fighter cowboy
Cerrone there Oh Cowboys wrong somehow
had the pleasure gold and visiting the
gym and the gentleman Mike who picked me
up and drove me back and forth was
telling me the filled explosion in
Albuquerque and how they're shooting
everything yeah they still got the tax
break at the tax break you know when
those guys were shooting Breaking Bad on
I mean bought houses down there but they
had to sell the houses because of the
high burglary in crime rate really your
car gets broken into a lot he found the
Mexicans and [ __ ] from over the water
and who knows who stole it
it's funny this is a funny story about
20 years ago when I step on the road
years ago I was a big reader when I
first moved here I was enamored with the
Bahia because from my first for my
second audition yeah to my sixth is gone
mob course of course and I went out for
a movie here that was never made and it
was about a Queens crew oh yeah the
people were [ __ ] more yeah who shows
about a mob script 9 or 10 times the
[ __ ] every mobster I know eventually had
a script so you know this we had a we we
had a sh go down to that building on
Sunset and the vine on the bottom on the
corner you'll be a building that's got
redone yeah I was a coffee being across
yeah there's a little seafood restaurant
that blows across the street that I
ordered spaghetti and clam sauce ah with
shrimp and they gave me shrimp on the
weekend off I almost [ __ ] I should
burn it down so I went there and the guy
offered me a ton of money for this movie
I never forget that he asked me about
these characters and I didn't know I
knew that world but I know who he was
talking about and I went on the road and
I would go to true-crime and every five
hours I got half of it went to blow but
yeah the Barnes and Nobles I just you
read up on stir bar I hate used books I
hate when somebody needs a [ __ ] you
really drives me crazy I want to read
the book really yeah he asked me create
a taking a bathroom they [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
no I don't want to read nobody else here
it's all tacked up so I unless I know
you yeah yeah so I started reading all
this truth
I'm [ __ ] and I read about this guy I
read about I read about Whitsett there
was a book called WITSEC for a while
know that and in WITSEC they gave a lot
of the mummies for them to give out this
much information there was a guy who
wrote about the pitfalls of WITSEC I
don't know what that is if this book
wants to come out in 97 what's--what SEC
WITSEC the witness read okay okay I'm
like I thought in that era it was all
about about that when mobsters I'm doing
a WITSEC Pro okay how hard their lives
become like they had the example of a
guy that went in but while he went in he
made a cookbook and yeah he got on let
him and like I remember that yeah yeah
you cannot go on Ava Letterman David
Letterman yeah so he told the feds to go
[ __ ] themselves he got the David
Letterman David Letterman canceled ah
said I can't put you on now because I'm
you created too much [ __ ] half-hour
god
so it was [ __ ] crazy but it had about
what was that good sound that they set
up yeah WITSEC was a book about the
town's they had set up right right and
set up towns to put different witness
relocations in that town so would be
easy for them to monitor sure hysterical
and they had the list of cities and then
they had to live they all they think
they took a book and they wrap it around
Henry Hill really sure it wasn't about
Henry Hill but they had an exams most
famous rat oh wow the witness relocation
plan is really destructive because just
because you move them so [ __ ] Nebraska
doesn't mean they stop stealing a
criminal unable they go [ __ ] bananas
well they look [ __ ] bananas you know
I'm driving down the street and I see
these people don't lock their door yeah
yeah what are you [ __ ] crazy right I'm
gonna Rob it right your garage is open
or the track no I know a guy who my
trailers down the corner you know so the
prom they were having the rate of
recidivism yeah they even did a movie
called my Blue Heaven I think was D Ryan
brilliant a movie where they took all
the stories and how that's what happens
so they would move let's say me and
Benza
I was with the Gambino's and Benza was
with the [ __ ] Genovese they would
take us and put us both in a suburb of
Houston yeah and like take their chances
of us bumping into each yeah that's
right
and how many people on the town will
witness windows protection they were 50%
three four they put two mobsters now
they're right they put two mobsters a
Jew attorney who had information on
Marcos yeah a couple that did drug
pushing right for the Cali cartel yeah
so you would know they need to just be
regular people but it was is easier for
the feds to monitor yeah that's all one
of the towns that they have now with the
Albuquerque was I think they Rio
something and that was one of the cities
there I mentioned in this yeah yeah and
I heard through the years that that's
where they said Big Joe Messina oh wow
yeah interesting doing radio then and
I'm talking to him they go that's funny
because I heard Big Joe Massino down
anything Angus that's funny because the
restaurant the best Italian restaurant
big Joe's now Kenny huh with Sammy the
Bulls and Feeny opened up a restaurant
in Phoenix and the slogan of it was the
best-kept secret
best-kept secret best-kept secrets are
you [ __ ] playing a face right in
their face and that's a Weinstein eight
by accident complete accident I had a
story that yeah yeah but [ __ ] Sammy's
joint thinking there was Loki whatever
he thought but it was the worst place to
go and it's also funny you know of all
the places to go you gotta go Sammy
maybe he was told to go there because he
did Mob Wives on now on TV maybe maybe
he heard from Karen Gravano that her dad
has a open the place and doesn't know it
anymore
no I sold it yeah I think the mother
walked back to work there for a while
but still but I thought still
family-owned in some capacity or maybe
it was no good once if that's coming
back to see you lose everything
nothing yeah restaurant yeah the [ __ ]
there's like 700 thousand a month yeah
he was things clean no he was the makin
some dough I can't imagine cuz like I I
didn't grow up with the internet I came
when I was a teenager but when you live
even
enjoy you have stories of going to
Florida to be on the lam but it like
that yeah I don't even think that's
possible really anymore look it'd be
really hard beached went to beach town
no I could do it yeah well you wouldn't
be stupid and open about a comedy cup
called joeys or you put a hat you shaved
your head you put a hat on sure you mix
into the community but never really just
enough you know stand out enough so you
don't stand up sure you don't make any
commotion you know how that night at all
you have to live like in the third
season of narcos at the end they said
that the guys all say no that ratted on
narcos is somewhere in the antrum right
now you see him working as a mechanic
right and he's waiting on wine on the
Kentucky Fried Chicken but often they
show the camera I could cook a fried
chicken how that's a complete different
world of its own
yeah yeah I can tree hill Henry Hill
with there's seven different locations
yeah I think wants to have it he was a
problem yeah he was a riot
he was constantly prompt he was a
problem in Memphis Tennessee even when
he was out and lived in LA he was a
[ __ ] problem eat when he was out of
the witness protection there's the last
few years in LA he was a lunatic he was
still causing [ __ ] and getting drunk all
the time time I saw you know what I
never shook the guy's hand he was at a
bench probably hill I always thought he
was the kiss of death
oh yeah first time I was at the store if
somebody came up to me like one of the
front
Henry holds up dead talk eventually I
got my car and I drove out of there as
fast as I [ __ ] could well good what
good can every time what I did the other
guy the other guy the other rats movie
who I love I love salawats
I don't know so hello so yeah I used to
live here now over there okay and I just
spoke to about three weeks ago salawats
was the first first first guy in a rat
God what's his last name robots that's
not real that means great was Leslie
BOTS means crazy so I don't know sappers
really wrong
hey guys he's crude but arena no no it's
funny because like I always understood
why Sammy rolled because he was very
smart smarter I knew no numbers no
numbers he knew how to negotiate he knew
exactly where the body is they had bet
he knew that if he didn't go first yeah
Sammy knew yeah he went Sammy was so
good that when he went first they
wouldn't believe nobody else until they
finally had so much testimony that Sammy
did sell drugs yeah that they said this
can't be like everybody's coming in here
saying Sammy's on drugs yeah but [ __ ]
he's saying that he never sold a drug in
his life
the last time they put him in because he
said he never shot a cop he was been the
guy that gave the Iceman the [ __ ] job
to kill that guy yeah man so they put
him in jail for that and the Iceman died
by mistake
what's a lo BOTS now police he isn't
your [ __ ] horse I know some places yeah
I didn't know BOTS okay yeah it's crazy
because when you look at a rat you go oh
he's a rat yeah [ __ ] him he's a rat he
did this listen this but as I got older
I understood the differences yeah all
right I'll just put the differences
sometimes we get him like I can't think
of I think of The Sopranos hmm and I
walk in my house and I go what if I was
totally surprised if I just came from
Shenzhen Bali and I gotta come in the
house and play with my kid like the cops
are gonna knock on my door yeah I just
came from a wire room where [ __ ] I'm
taking a [ __ ] on [ __ ] whatever
there's chicks there that's sucking my
dick you know half the crews on blow you
gotta come home not to do coke right and
you got you drinking all day you gotta
come home so I will never comprehend
them no I can't like I can't imagine
somebody kicking my door down I can't
imagine opening my door with mercy and
somebody driving by and shooting at me
because I made the wrong decision I
can't
but imagine even like if she John Gotti
cuz I used to see him out you know
imagine him doing what he was doing
running in a lot of places here and
there but then and [ __ ] beautiful
women and then eventually he's got to go
home to the little house in Howard Beach
what the wife and the old bedrooms I'm
sure they have old furniture from from
the third year of marriage I bet there's
still stuff in there from their first 10
years of marriage a couch you know the
plastic gondola something how do you
[ __ ] go for an out world but he did it
for a good amount of time now really
running the [ __ ] family and then
going back to he didn't have the big
mansion like Bay like Paulie Castellano
he didn't do [ __ ] like that
he was flashy with his suits and his
flashy in public with certain people but
you know he loved he loved that people
he really liked that agya Latian for
people even when I used to go see him in
court he'd come out of the car it was
like it was like a movie because that's
what they loved it the Mafia it's just
so dramatic and what they do you know if
you're black gangster you come on the
car a different person you're an Italian
gangsta come on you got hundred-dollar
bills for the homeless guy you kiss the
[ __ ] news woman who's always on your
back with the money you people start to
love seeing you you know it's a
different type of gangster Mexican
gangster doesn't come out his house
loving people loving him around the
table I still always like the guy who
drives the 69 car beat-up yeah who has
jeans with a hole there who's playing
stupid right I'll never forget going to
this place when I was a kid on 42nd
Street right around the corner from the
Lincoln Tunnel and you went to get your
dick sucked there it was like a long
[ __ ] Street railings probably forty
sixth reality first me when I [ __ ]
was there was a long street had a couple
friends would go to and family and my
dick suck and we'd have to get out of
the car and sit I remember that yeah we
did that to high school I don't know yet
like girls walking oh oh my god no what
you guys don't want to get your dick
sucked the Willing thing
whatever yeah and one day my friend said
where's your pen and this was early on
like juniors in high school after we had
no pen for the whole game right [ __ ]
I'll never forget there was a guy in the
wheelchair I was in the corner yeah and
one day somebody said to me
next time you go over yeah make sure the
guy with the wheelchair in the corner
and I went over there just to drive
somebody one day right and I saw that
guy I put towards to again see that's
weird they go well deserved these wheels
he's got a machine gun and he's playing
handy oh really
he'd have to sign any money that well he
had a gun under that he would shoot you
it had a suck your dick on that block I
remember that block was [ __ ]
disgusting we know well we went it was
1980 79 80 81 and we thought 42nd Street
cuz that's where the show world was but
the peep shows and [ __ ] with the windows
that come up but then for the for
[ __ ] we found out you gotta go on
the west side 10th to have you 11th day
I mean we went by there was a UPS
facility for the poor truck saw it also
happens to be where they take the horse
characters from Central Park outside the
plaza the carriages go back to 10th
Avenue and 47th Street so we found that
one night a bunch of carriages and then
they're open and the hookers would come
down a street like it was the neither
like was Walking Dead the TV show like
zombies like 20 of them at once and you
know you had your pick and five guys in
the Cadillac you know from Long Island
with [ __ ] 40 dollars in our pocket
you know we took a change were robbed
one of my friends got blown was pants
around his ankles and as the girl was
blowing she was putting his finger thing
is in his back pocket inside his wallet
without it would rub and rub behind your
back she's taking the money out put it
while on the way back to Long Island
I had $40 I'm I am the money we were
[ __ ] oh yeah they were pickpockets
ahead of me you know how is [ __ ] will
you teach a bus teach right yeah my
neighborhood there was one Bobby Pierce
and he hung around with teacher must eat
this is 1980 to 1981 1983 teacher bus
teach used to call me rubber because
your face is like rubber he used to
and your rubber he used to hear and mana
from it and they will get into arguments
at one another [ __ ] deal you don't know
what you're talking about
a 79 Corvette is better than six all
right there were two [ __ ]
knuckleheads so I heard a story about
them going in the city one night because
chicha must each always had always had
some type of saying yeah always had
something and there in this city they go
and they gonna get their dicks on her an
abandoned building uh-huh
both deadpan sit down the chicks are
about to suck their dick and they both
pull out pieces and two gorillas come
out from the back releases oh my god
give us your money and cheetah busty
stands around he goes Bob like it's not
like anything else you can say like [ __ ]
you whatever he goes Bob I'm not giving
you a dime and they put the gun to his
head and they took his belt his cash his
[ __ ] car shoes he came back yeah man
teach about stitch I never saw him again
he got a him and his buddy Bobby Pierce
got arrested for cop stealing you got to
be careful in the seventies and eighties
sure when you wouldn't Bob well they're
sucking your dick they're taking the
wall out of your pocket it was amazing
was [ __ ] amazing if they were doing
over there those [ __ ] they were just as
good at giving your head is they weren't
robbing you dad there are multi-talented
girls but we want one time broke loose
of a high school field trip was seen all
probably play in the 40s and that's how
we found the 10/40 club the guys in the
group of us a year they would tell us
when they were seniors we used to get we
had a [ __ ] and get laid hold you I'm
56
I went to the 10/40 Club I was 17 years
old all right and them all to Moses that
was at the end I mean it was never never
beautiful no no that was the most
disgusting it was that was the joint my
1980s of my life yeah till this day yeah
whenever I think that going in there's a
tenner yeah my wife sleep yeah and I
retired that memory flashes into my head
because that was the first time I
learned
one never going to call with somebody
yeah yeah yeah meet me I'll jump myself
yeah because your friends a pet who
knows what the [ __ ] person I feel my
friend's name is Pedro Pagani was a
Cuban guy and what do you found that I
don't know I was his human cancer there
was a handful of a bit of the alley
brothers wanna Ollie in Hobart Ollie one
was the brains of the operation I teach
a bus station and I Bardot was just a
[ __ ] and he would agree to everything
wrong when they were 12 in the 6th grade
on the weekends they would go into the
city well to get their dicks on
different looking houses Wow and tell us
the story on one day as the brother
would be like the yeah the brother was
half [ __ ] that and they work at
their father's shop during the week and
once avid all their dads they were going
on comic books for [ __ ] play and they
would take buses into the city yeah you
know I don't know how they found that
yeah and they would tell you worried I
think you find out we found out for the
kids above us but then with the first
time you went we'd left the school play
you know at least the mow lawns for
[ __ ] money you know five hours at a
time and we had enough we pop lockers in
gym one period and we ended up coming at
it like 60 bucks from kids wallets so we
know we got money for 10 40 broke loose
of a play was that play with Harry
Chapin an off-broadway play and we
[ __ ] go to 10:40 we thought 10 bucks
we get a son know that gets you the room
and then the girl gives you the [ __ ]
menu of course wha we we all went back
in the Lindell and the [ __ ] hallway
at the same time we were out of money we
had like 10 bucks apiece we couldn't get
[ __ ] but the room one girl took pity on
my buddy uh you know more the most
mature guy and she he [ __ ] her but
then we told that story to the great
underneath this but we used to get head
in the [ __ ] buggies from the Plaza
Hotel they Paul come on in the 40s and
the Tenth Avenue and that was the place
you'd sit in so you know you one night
there's there's a black hooker bolonia
and the next day some newlywed couple of
going around Central Park you know
drinking champagne from the plaza not
only this just amazing how differently I
was just thinking about like 12 like the
biggest thing when I when I was in
school was tenth grade we took a class
trip to DC and
every year all the kids would sneak off
on their one three time and go to
Hooters and I had a cousin I didn't even
go to I went to my cousin's house with
little kids and had a beer I thought I
was so cool but they liked it the big
thing with them going to Hooters and you
guys are talking about going and getting
hookers at sixteen my mother was dead
maybe a year and I knew Pedro but God's
dead on the candy company huh and they
had a truck and then late you've got in
the car with him and it was a truck you
ride truck stopped yeah lollipops and
M&M is actually fathers had a company
had 20 trucks they supplied everything
in New York on candy and one night he
picks me up in the truck it's my
birthday like him and six other guys and
we actually went to ten forty club yeah
you paid the ten dollars and I walked
into a room yeah it's disgusting it's
just not like men would come on yeah
that's why I really learned about men
all those good-looking guys are paying
they get [ __ ] yeah there were more of
them hi great thank I'll glia factor oh
yeah there will hold good-looking guys
in there that look like Theo von dressed
up the Cologne then ugly fat yeah dirty
guys yeah and women will come out like
seven out of time and you would have to
grab them yeah and you would negotiate
for more dough and I'll never forget I
took in the back $10 she'll [ __ ] me
straight yeah she put the cup before
they put the condom on you they wash
your dick with a bomb but my dad do you
use bucket yeah I don't wash it under
the bed yeah yep gonna do I don't know
Lee with a sponge that would be was you
exactly sold they wash your balls a mom
then they put a condom on you then they
they wouldn't put it on with that mouth
and the girl got on top of me and she
looked great on paper yeah right with
the soup but when she took her legs well
she'd been stabbed yes I got a dog [ __ ]
it cesarean section started disgusting
and she's on top of me trying to [ __ ] me
and I all I can think about is like is
this poetry in flowers this had a high
said to me for an exit
oh I could hear the rubber hitting her
ma no aah
and she goes for the next $10 I'll let
you eat me you kill me there was a
little sink my cousin's prison sick and
overtook tomorrow so I dicker my balls
she's like eh you okay I'm left my
friends dad take a bus back home when I
never talk to that kid again it could be
traumatic was the one I remember that
the lighting was awful
and I remembered that could we have a
couple times the first time I was too
young I couldn't even get a hard-on at
all
I still don't the two or three times I
went there it's gonna be a blow job and
then I'd be but even that I don't get as
turn I can't get turned on I don't know
the chick she's not somebody I like
she's not a chick that I find beautiful
I can't get turned on by a hooker I
can't and I mean even like a hot like a
great body
they just know this fingerprints all
over them people yeah I guess crazy
they're all around here but I'll tell
you what ever since that dude said no
listen it's I go to one Chinese massage
place because they open up sure they're
really on the up-and-up over there they
it's 45 hours forty dollars they rub
your feet with water I
they rub you down it's either a guy or a
girl the girls are [ __ ] beasts yeah
[ __ ] but that's what you want yeah
you know and but you know what I made
the mistake to go and put the one across
the street too one day
oh my god does it have a happy ending
joint it's one of those happy ending and
I knew it but I walked in I said another
this is why I go why first the law hike
you cannot touch your dick you cannot
touch my dick with that hand make him
one time you know I love to my wife
yeah that's my dick with that creepy
five that has to be disgusting hey even
if they were not [ __ ] you know I can't I
just can't have you know when I was
about 15 I had a best friend of mine
that was still to this day we're gold
bars come to me and he goes I need a
favor take a ride with me
he had the clap oh and we went to a clap
place like the hub the palm laughing
because oh do you take that fish food
and he [ __ ] there was a chick there
and a guy that had like ha
sores around his mouth now and that went
into my head yeah
like [ __ ] like Jesus yeah and I never
forgot that and for some reason I'm a
dirty [ __ ] you like my movies I throw at
all but you know what no no no no no I
was really I was young I the prude [ __ ]
oh yeah got the whole Latino background
oh yeah he's ball element of it yeah
yeah you know it's crazy that I used to
have a Cuban guy when I was like in the
fourth to the fifth grade there was a
Cuban guy he used to hang around my
mother's body shouting his name was Elio
he was on quoi
I'm [ __ ] what they him in a bunch of
clown doing the talking and he pointed
me out he's like if somebody wants to
suck your dick they suck your dick
whether it's a man as long as you know
suck their dick they make sure not fair
you want you to [ __ ] him in the ass
welcome in here that was damn machismo
yeah that was their level of machismo
that there's a I'm not a [ __ ] your effect
that kind of thing I'm no [ __ ] your
[ __ ] you didn't [ __ ] me oh yeah those
good guys down south like that y-yeah
yeah no fact they had when I was a kid
my mom would always call me boo out
wrong and I would go with the [ __ ]
move our own is is a dude who in prison
he [ __ ] he takes a guy and he goes
leave from that one yeah I like that put
a wig on yeah lipstick on yeah a nice
shadow on you I want you to shave your
ball in the ass and you take all this
from me like you do my laundry you cook
okay but what is that what is it I get
that you gotta hold your [ __ ] belt
loop the whole thing here's the deal you
[ __ ] them yeah they suck your dick but
they don't [ __ ] you that's it no they
don't I think it's Mack right like women
smack I'm winking but I need to know
what that is what my man is that I don't
get it
never met one complaint that's a
prisoner plus are they are they oh yeah
other places in prison in Cuba did they
have it before prison
I don't it's not something I want to do
before pretty are they latent homosexual
I want to go to prison
yeah I can't imagine I just can't are
you let's have you come let's have a
drawer like to do life I knew that then
it was a drug deal and he had been in
prison I guess he was in prison one of
the guys and when he came out he hired
his cousin put a wig on him and they hug
Ozzie they held the coke on the street
with heels on holy [ __ ] straight breasts
really and he would sell coke on the
street in San Francisco Wow
so when they a friend to me I when I
went to San Francisco lady five had a
Warren in Jersey and basically I was
doing in San Francisco was a con man I
had a suit and I could go to hotels
every day with a Wall Street Journal and
I'd sit low ambient way for people to
check in I listened to what room number
they were going and then run upstairs
ten minutes afterwards and I neither
steal the maid's keys because in those
days was always trying to keep right the
maids would stick the keys in the door
leave a dorm with the keys hanging there
I find out where the maid wasn't right
in a clock and take her keys what once I
had the master key you couldn't stop my
god I must be I'd wait he's a hawk and
so there was I lived in the Tenderloin
I lived in a place called The Virginian
Hotel which is now the hostel and across
the street from there I was there
helping that was my prime spot so I
would wake up at 7:00 and go to the home
and sit there with the master key and
there was no cameras in those days and
I'd wait three to check-in time no
cameras and I was doing it but this is
where I got greedy I was doing it up two
or three different hotels I had a guy I
would buy it from me no questions asked
no ID right down the corner really
and then the Cubans I I met these
refugee Cubans that are coming from
Mario and they were real deal yeah right
they were real deal sure and their
sponsor on the block was an old guy
called it poodle so whatever you made
for the day you got to give him a cup he
has the oh yeah I think he owned the
corner right Tribune you hustled
can you do on that quantity you could
sell coke good so we've you can mug
somebody but my answer thing in those
days was there was a Cuban thief
that specialized in traveler's checks
Wow he didn't know the language yeah
so for 50 percent I would go to Japanese
pen time up in northern San Francisco
they wouldn't ask for ID on the American
Express I would put a suit on in the
world and just take something that was
thirty to fifty with a holla go yeah I'm
gonna get expressed me right and I'd pay
for it until I got all the cash back and
then we'd split the cash and take the
merch I'm Selva Mercia he was like
[ __ ] stealing yeah I did that for a
[ __ ] summer I mean I was a one-man I
not F yeah and I worked for myself yeah
it's just beautiful well yeah now that
was bad days sure but there was good
days when you had bad days you always
went to Buddha was so let me get 50 K
and I'll give you 65 tomorrow when no
listen raise s well when my my mind
roommate Chico ran again he's like you
when he was the one of the security guys
at scores but he elevated to a position
where yeah you know it's a mom joint
even the the girls kicked up to the
security critic he sucked at a
management manic except for the agent
crazy yeah I want to kicks up to the mob
it's all kick up right and so Chico
every night this is my wall street's
Bullman Bill Clinton's president every
night there was two or three credit
cards that people every week two or
three cards would be forgot but by it by
a Wall Street guy not just some guy who
drove in from Jersey he's gonna call
right in the next morning but a Wall
Street guy who goes to work late the
next day he's on the floor he don't
[ __ ] care about his Amex the minute
we got is we had to put a guy that on
suits tours on - damn you where'd
electronic stores down on Bowery when we
got one of those cards the mall Doolin's
we call them we call those friends for
stereo equipment for suits we whack out
the card and the call would only be
charged 50 bucks the client would get
all I got to pay 50 bucks my Amex was
stolen it was looking small penalty
Amex would pay for the rest of the [ __ ]
because it was theft no cameras we'd
split the [ __ ] we buy he give us suits
we give him cash it was [ __ ] great
I even kept cards even after they were
hot you could sell them know how we keep
cards because I would go to Chinese
restaurant
and get the lunch special it was in
those days was before 95 with a can of
soda 5 yeah that I I would leave a seven
dollar favor well I gotta open up the
book and look at the numbers there was
no computer it was no computer there was
no scam it was the DIA so I always ate
lunch on a [ __ ] stolen credit card
right leave the card just was the same
way it was the thing right it was an
emporium print thing and at the end the
day they deposited the bank and the bank
shoots it back this is a stolen card and
if that pro so i would go two days in a
row then i would disappear to a gyro
place two days and then once I get go
back I would never do it at my favorite
restaurants you don't [ __ ] where you
sleep right
so you always kept the car yeah the car
it was a day like I can't even like
today that's completely different cryin
oh wow
people wanna lie and steal your card
you're done but in the old days I mean I
remember the first time I was exposed to
it was a friend of mine well I'm still
in contact with his mom yeah all you had
was gold with mothers oh listen I need
to Apple computer 19 inches
yeah I'm 3 I Pro cameras and three
microphones she go on the internet not
today she'd alright the three mics are
140 apiece the computer 1600 you want to
let 3200 that's 48 right give me 50 500
I'll be here tonight at six o'clock give
me three thousand cash right what are
you gonna say only yeah well because I
just saved you 50 for sure three
thousand cash tonight like that that's
how quick it was because she had cards
she would even get me jeans
yeah that's like usually 30 to 34 I'll
get you three of them jeans in those
days with 12 dollars a piece
it's over 29 yeah got three pair of
[ __ ] Levi well Norman loses the guy
that on the suit store you bought four
suits you whacked him he was inaudible
even though he knew he was a friend of
laws he'd open up I want these three
suits here you go boom he makes money
for the shop and if you want to sell the
suit you can be like wearing suits so he
made money and went famine the guy
reported a stolen Amex is only
responsible for a certain amount
I mean the whole map the stores only
response was like 50 bucks some small
Alex pays all that but they mailed me
they their gosh in time one time they
had me but they didn't what had happened
was I was a real [ __ ] gavone I had a
friend who got cards and for about six
months I tapped the cards very lightly I
was very small smart about trying to get
my life together I wasn't doing blow
right I had just turned 22 or 21 and it
was the first time I hadn't done blowing
like six years
all my I started at 79 huh and New
Year's 84 said that's it Wow [ __ ] but
I still dabbled with the weed I didn't
drink then yeah it wasn't about drinking
and a friend of mine I bumped into a man
and when Danny goes can you move credit
cards I don't even move because they
don't use them I called oh yeah there's
no ID but just go to places that you
know right the people know so you go to
a restaurant Lee come in just don't let
it go right so charge charge it and I'll
give you a lower tip right and you make
a hundred give them up yeah
get yourself up afraid to go right you
get a waiter so I cut the deal with you
you're my friend I grew up with you
you're not gonna get in trouble you
didn't know I don't know you don't know
nothing he had motive stolen I know so I
would go to places that you worked late
we'd run up a tab and then I'd say give
yourself a 307 give me 100 yeah you got
a do you have no idea yeah yeah people
there was money everywhere and then I
moved to Boulder and I'm walking around
that must be a Wild West
I got I got 18 grand I got angry into
the bank account and they grant cash in
my room and I'm down to four grand I go
what am i doing
oh my [ __ ] Johnny there baby I called
my buddy Ron the car yeah yeah I went to
the car now I'll put it in the [ __ ]
mail tomorrow
it was all but the problem nobody would
buy stolen merchants but that's not the
involved we weren't the guys driving
around on the cars with like the mr.
bossy extra seafood knows the worst you
know no that's something another speaker
well the say you live next to me yeah
like I had a buddy who next to me who
did steroids didn't belong with them one
day you want to buy the sorry yeah you
know every hot merch was not as bold and
come on oh I got to keep [ __ ] once in a
while people would buy a riot the only
thing people would buy from me were pens
I used to go into those stores antiques
and us all those gonna have their frames
oh oh and I would steal cross pen oh no
how would I would hotel elated you can I
have the clothespin and this chick would
go open up the bottom drawer and then
somebody else would distract her she
shrank the key and leave the draw oh god
and I take all the gold covered ones and
take him back the [ __ ] in the car dealer
shot so yeah I was gonna say businessmen
loved that no no I was I was always a
50-percent type again yeah I stole it so
yeah right you know yeah it's perfect
[ __ ] craziness crazy that [ __ ]
craziness of being gone and I remember
being at the Baltimore one time summer
of 85
it's August I'm walking to his mall the
21 years old trying to get my life
together I'm walking to this mall of
Lorna I cannot believe that this is
happening like that if I had my friend
damn ring or he got rest his soul
we'd make a million dollars yeah I'd
seen a year in high school we would both
have like Jim at 10:45 we would get in
his car in high school we were juniors
and drive up to see his robot huh
and open up see at the back door whether
you're a morning while y'all just ran by
the back door there was a stack of car
speakers oh god Blaupunkt without
partner yeah
back then and only as it was walking
yeah like a pair of walk out we get 35
bucks
we must get 35 bucks yeah that's 70
that's a half a grandmother also you
need a $10 bag of weed a 6-pack of beer
yeah we would do that three days a week
until every box was gone
it's great see every [ __ ] buy every
box Louise and I'm embarrassed to say
these stories but then that you never
[ __ ] tell you when I was 16 17 we're
living on Long Island and good
neighborhood but we were the poorest
family you know why my father was older
and everybody was young company but a
few a few of the developments of those
were all the new houses going up with
the younger money you know and I have a
go my father had a big Cadillac and I
would go at night with a shovel dressed
in black and I dig out I mean I love
hedges and plants and I know what's
expensive what Pines would [ __ ] I
know all about plants for some reason I
would Rob every beautiful hedge young
rose bushes I know what everything costs
and I bring him back and my father knew
I was doing this I put him I was like it
was like a tribute dad look what I got
last night I put him in the yard by the
pool before he went to work he go I like
that pine yeah put that rhododendron
over there that's nice give that tour
Rosalee and then some laughter you guys
down the street heard I was doing it and
they go you know can you grab us some of
these yeah so I started going out but
fathers Cadillac I lined it back with
news but the glad bags and that was
one-man operation I dig [ __ ] and they
were in the earth for like a few days
they weren't like sunk in you just pick
him out put him in the trunk room cuz no
one lived in the model homes yet was all
homes that were furnished and the
landscaping was done but nobody lived
there there was no cameras once again
it's a model development and was a good
hustle for like a summer I missed my few
grand and they paid $50 for a bush this
one a bonsai tree that good-looking [ __ ]
did you ever get the same house like
multiple times when they kept refilling
like you know I got a school that way I
got the school across not across the
street and down the block from my house
and I could then I got to be like I
can't keep it in the school they kept
putting his beautiful super spray in
that four foot high I'd pull out of the
ground and you had do it during the
winter when things when the root ball is
still gonna be alive my father let me do
that [ __ ] he thought it was so funny I
never got one of the sickest things I
did was I got involved with Waldo my
neighborhood friends it was like
Sabatino call us did you bust eats no
future must eat results can that school
guy
this was the given that guitarist crew
in those days that was Carlos Perez me
Sabatino Dominic's mushy how God bless
his soul come all the kids I may forget
there was a soccer field
it's called shits in Park shuts in right
in Union City it's been there since
[ __ ] before Hitler and it's a German
place that serves German food but they
also cater it out you have parties oh
yeah
so they have all the political parties
we were kids they practice baseball back
there North Bergen had the rights to
practice Little League baseball back
there and there was a soccer field like
this on the weekends the German soccer
team would play back there yeah and it
was basically a headstands yeah I don't
know what you could fit in there I don't
know 2003 thousands of Park but it was
covered by this 10-day always covered oh
okay it was covered by this ten roof and
four years four years starting I mean I
remember going up there when I wasn't
like ten and hitting balls with ritenour
the Todd brothers by the way one of them
just died the Jeff Tom Jim rich Todd
vana check him we go up there on old and
playboy but there was a guy back there
that his name was the butcher and if he
caught you back there he chased you with
a knife German Shepherd Oh
Shepherds for the dog back then but the
beautiful of it we used to go up there
and ride the motorcycles and that would
really drop he would chase you and set
all those who of zing ah yeah right
but we figured out one day somebody told
me I used to my mother first died I had
all these different friends and I had
good people my life but I had this one
particular kid Mike Benny everybody
called him the devil my people guys the
devil yeah I took a liking to my hair my
daddy was a short wrestler I went to
Lehigh the eye and but he just had him
you know you know he was one of those
guys that every time you did some women
do you trouble you came up short
Oh
I'm gonna believe my house if I gave me
300 instead of five yeah I tolerated it
for about a year and I had lost him as a
friend yeah but I will tell you he was
the money-making machine when they came
to make money at night the problem with
him was he robbed all the wrong people
his father owned a ship refurbishing
company so when the ship lands in Newark
roboking the more days after six months
at sea right they come in weld off all
the morning campaigns a big job stake
and they get year contra that's a big
job well he would go back at night and
steal the whole Oh crying steal the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that belong to the ship oh
yeah he was just a [ __ ] [ __ ] Chris
I'm snorting coke with him yeah listen
eros forget you wins an rx-7
he's gotta be 20 and I'm 16 right and
that little crew we put together one day
somebody mentioned that that tendon
above the soccer field then you could
sell it's worth something yeah like
copper like copper wiring
listen everybody in my neighborhood got
a ratchet set that night before you went
out Lee you had you took out your ratty
of clothes and we go up there me and you
every night at seven o'clock cuz butcher
would get off butch it was off I just
got an 80 to the back so we get up there
climb and ratchet those pigs [ __ ]
bathrobe off yeah you had a slide off
the girl off it was [ __ ] scary and I
mean little by little you saw section
disappear yeah Lee it was [ __ ] what
could he do it was like a little by
little every night then then then
somebody else caught on so I would steal
a sheet and he would steal a sheet and
then he told his friend his two friends
started stealing sushi yeah so now we
almost turned into a war like wait a
second this is our curfew we've had this
first me in the deserts in Pakistan
Harlow and Sabatino at this first dog
they [ __ ] stripped every piece yeah a
[ __ ] ten shits in Park had a put a
tarp over that's great for the soccer
that was a hustle for a whole [ __ ]
summer and we were getting like fifty
five hours a thing there was so many
people I used to bring things to
yeah those I don't know what those
people are anymore I just don't know how
to have a transmission guy yeah that
would give me some money for sawdust no
because they fill raw fish yeah yeah
yeah where do you get sawdust farm be
lumpy on sorry someone I used to work in
a lumberyard they don't clean up every
night and when I got the job the kid
that had the job before me he told me
right off the Vagos listen to me you
gotta steal because if you don't steal
the gun I was stealing the boss I have
existing contracts are you kidding me
and I go what he talkin about he goes on
salaries a guy comes and bites 40 sheets
of plywood help give me $400 cash give
me a hundred from now on and I got
another guy that comes on Thursdays and
gets 20 she timber his marine plywood
was $64 a sheath right by 8:00 right he
would say and it was galvanized yeah the
palumbo yeah yeah so he would say you're
charging the 20th sheet I I mean there
was days that's a lot to remember there
was days when me and for gorillas would
load the back up and at the end of the
day there was no sheets left no I was
just I was a junior yeah I was robbing
the house yeah yeah it was a family and
transmission place and they would tell
me when the barrels get filled up give
us a call Sean wasn't allowed to sweep
up I think I would sweep and put him
bowels and once I get five barrels and
give me the Kandra cash which was every
week ha ha ha you caption once a time
the job pay me six bucks an hour yeah
you got another probably minutes down
yeah you gotta go right they had an
old-school register so which meant if
you spent $8 damn I ain't a house but if
you came in I'd say how you don't tell
her nothing right no Joey nice to meet
you are you looking for I'm redoing my
base bunny ten sheets of four by eight
ply with a 44 hours of peace you know
ten sheets at four forty right I knew
that plus tax
all right I would [ __ ] do the
register hmm I would do it um I compiled
it was a calculator but I mean the
register would be packed them before
self
right in front of them they didn't know
that I had loaded the sheets huh I would
take the sheet and ba-ba-ba-ba-bom and
do the tax like 4 4 40 yes tax and
instead of ringing in 488 I'd ring in 88
I think I would give me $488 my panini
the register keeps 400 sure unlocked the
register I did this every day yeah but
okay that's how I store the coke my
sophomore junior year and then there was
an old school gangster in there rather
than mention his name and his angle as
he was buying nickels and stones
he wasn't buying nickels and stones he
just said that his party was bra I said
he was buying stolen gem yeah [ __ ]
diamond rings she saw on top of that I
had friends that were burglars and I
told him I knew mr. B and they would
give me stuff for him his round never
forget one Saturday I found the bureau
there was a bureau on the street that
somebody had moved and me and my buddy
said I wonder if there's something in
there
and we shook it there was change ah as
good tips to change out and we put it we
should put the changed our 50 in corners
knees but that night when I went home
one of the dimes nickels was weird he
had I had Monday took it to him and he
took him look at it with the dials you
take 800 yeah [ __ ] kidding I'll take
10 cents for a nickel he gave me
anything
that's how honest he was it goes I mean
I'm gonna settle for 12 right now
Wow who knows he needs you got you this
a gold guy that's a specialist he
thought it'd be worth the wait you keep
100 off the time thanks a lot I had that
place wired for sound
yeah I wouldn't show up on Saturday so
it may have to have you every month at
would show this side now I would show up
on Saturdays and they would even say
them nah but right it's like you're
telling them like oh yeah my family used
to go I can't have ham for Christmas
dinner
but this is normal free yeah yeah this
was 16 17 years old Rendell London
that's young North Bergen New Jersey
this was when I quit the job the guy who
gave me the job told me you have to
steal if not they're gonna know he'll
know I was stealing for when he quit
that job you know like I'm the Sadie's
yeah
the Ando Yanis not even robbing a
heaven-born but it was a dirty
lumberyard because they did dirty
business and an account with the town
yeah which meant and if if AJ Benza was
a commissioner yeah he could redo his
garage sure I get him in town nobody
would know yeah and they would play like
they didn't know everyone was making
money every was a big game it was all it
was the biggest theory it was a big yeah
he lived and the guy who owned it led to
the town called Kenilworth New Jersey
hmm that's really rich it's nice place
yeah who else lose in Kenilworth New
Jersey I don't have the time I don't
know the greats and the butcher oh is
that right Wow
I used to have to go up there and see
the man and drop Veloz and stay in the
cars nice yeah nobody nobody you know
say now I lived with what my mother had
that barn we lived in North Bergen I
hung out with a family mm-hmm and their
family used to always take us on little
rides but let me tell you what I mean I
don't understand hustle because you
can't teach his child hustle now my kid
he's only kid ten but I just came out
Congress everybody had Chuck Taylors
tried everybody that mother had Chuck
Taylors I want you to find the song give
me your money please by TKO Oh bye-bye
and turning over our shy give me your
money please okay
every Saturday mornings at 7:30 in the
morning me and this guy Frankie B he
would pick me up when I was around 12 or
11 and we would drive to Englishtown New
Jersey to the funny car yeah I was a
track yeah England what they also had a
flea market
you
that was absolute that was the recipe
and he'd go but like I said to a
pharmacy give me the pharmacy and I'd
send them to this place in North Bergen
and I remember going there picking up
six bottles even the pharmacist would
look at me weird because there was such
a scam there was nothing was monitored
KnowledgeTree anymore no you had an
angle there was nobody who needed if you
didn't need a job you know how to work
the system number one you got a job you
went to that job for [ __ ] eight
months you were dedicated you didn't
miss you missed all the time but guess
what I have one daily a box felling you
hurt your back yeah some like you got a
law settlement and you're your
disability and they give you 450 a week
because you were making top dollar unit
so now you're making 1,800 a month right
right and you're not doing dick but
guess what you hang out with me so every
day you better get up a nickel yeah yeah
so either you make a nickel or you make
250 it's still great yeah you're pulling
down 18 and you're making two grand Han
and I would be all week at a bar eating
the [ __ ] Lobster for lunch and
calamari and watching General Hospital
easy because by 9:00 in the morning
we've already put three scans together
now all waiting for is for Johnny to
show up with that eight ball because
when I throw a grammar cut on it yeah
we're gonna sell it at cost but now you
and me have a grandma cook for tonight
tonight all we had to do is pay for
alcohol it was all day every move was
covered every move was covered and if
the move wasn't covered the move was
covered so I got a gram I got I got to I
got I got a 60 bucks Lee you got 40
let's buy a grandma blow
AJ's bartending at the federal tonight
right give him two bumps and it would
drink for free on that we can between
Allah built the best I mean we drink for
free and I'm talking about right $80
shot top-shelf and filet mignon the
whole thing but he takes care of the
whole thing at the bar I don't think
that you know just like that forgiving
them 20 bucks and two lines of coke and
maybe putting a quaalude on the table I
always out every week let me tell you
when I came out teller in New York I put
20 dollars in everybody's hands twenty
dollars in everybody's hands
every doorman every chef every waiter
before tipping just cuz I'm in the room
that night and you know how far that
[ __ ] girl is just $20 in someone's
palm on a Tuesday night and the next day
you're there can you give me that suck
can you give me that can I get the drugs
and they got any pills you just wired in
that room the chef you're wired with him
you want about the maitre d's amazing
now you got ten restaurants antennas
they treat you like an animal Oh watch
it for the half a yard in the guy's hand
all different rest you got a table and
whole different restaurant and that's
what I do
according to my name you got a Christmas
I walk and I give him a hug behind you
put 50 Wi-Fi don't let the mood yeah
yeah I don't want to wait right fifty
pounds and I got Lee with me the steaks
on he's been dreaming if I totally on
Monday you think about me on Thursday
for chicken parmesan Danton he won't
leave me alone for three days and every
crustacean oh yeah I can't wait to go
yesterday
it was you know I'm home every other
week yeah and this times that
and then like I mean I like to think my
way for breakfast that's nice day a week
yeah
one day we do a lunches and Friday we do
date night but some nights I go you know
what I'd rather stay with the other one
yeah
I eat my edible and we watch Captain
Underpants say that's how I'm doing like
a [ __ ] I read for that five
o'clock I put her in the tub yeah and my
wife goes home at 9:30 ten years got to
business yeah she goes out with the
schoolteacher oh forget it and they they
they talk about kid yeah her sister and
she eats a dinner at least my wife gets
to get some oxygen that's good you know
so what the [ __ ] we throw we're talking
about getting people wide restaurants
$20 here Dan Tana's to stay so wait I
you know I forgot I'm [ __ ] high on
that we don't know what the [ __ ] them I
think you're gonna talk about the fried
rice no oh yeah yesterday oh wow yes sir
yesterday I I do a bunch of [ __ ] in the
morning you know I dropped her off but I
left my wife I think my wife wanted to
do breakfast I had it right
I had to meet this guy and I get home
and she comes in from shopping I know
she wants to talk to me but I just
walked in from kickbox
from jiu-jitsu which means for an hour
and a half I left my phone in the car oh
now I get it and there's seven message I
sent three people are definitely gonna
call back yeah so when I get home from
working out I take my dirty laundry so
as I walk in I throw the water by
mistake I turn the hot water on so
disinfected from my German I take the
ghee the rash guard the under one I
throw on the laundry basket
I said I saw the bag and I go in the
room and I put electrodes on my back oh
it's great and I put the computer on and
now I answer all those messages and all
those codes right with the electrodes in
my back I get up with the electrodes I
smoke a ball to get my appetite going
good once the electrodes wear off I take
him off and take a shower when I come
out my wife makes lunch
perfect so yesterday she came in I go
honey she goes I'm starving I can't
[ __ ] do this right now
let me his email see she was
disappointed here I'm sitting there
answering all this [ __ ] and right as I
was smoking that ball I had the
electrodes on my bag oh listen you're
hungry she doesn't [ __ ] starve
I go give me 20 minutes like another
cochinita okay now he's been sick
there's no ethnic food around here
Mama's sick now when you get sick guys
you go home the first night as soon as
you're feeling it you pop it there a flu
unless you got a prescription for those
pills Tamiflu yeah yeah you got to hold
on hold on to that even the expired yeah
that meat sure that's a [ __ ] wrap so
you take you should you feel a little
son and you take a little bit of weave I
gotta have frustrated with Leah and oh
he had bronchitis what I wanted him to
eat go to college get some go out you
celery and garlic there's just so much
things you up to eat right it's sick
I'll guarantee like a [ __ ] he
don't do that he's nothing you get your
blood moving man Jewish lightning you
gotta put tea with brandy oh the shot of
whiskey in there and then sweat it out
with a blanket yeah old grabbity Italian
juice wine you made honey that's good
and lemon
they want you to draft a well yeah they
want you to drink Triaminic and [ __ ]
[ __ ] drop so your fault is an old
Spanish grandmother everything Auto
Rican they break the soup with the
chicken balls any guys yeah super there
what's your right back to pop Magoo yeah
we don't have this here even though when
you have swen you get a cold the best
thing to drink old school what do women
wash their [ __ ] with vinegar sour soup
apple apple cider vinegar on the bottle
and sour soup
ohand sounds delicious you drink hot and
sour soup in your cold that vinegar
drink thinks the whole thing is the best
yeah how do your system sorry I had to
put alright now what do you want your
monkey with vinegar no I I every night i
gargle or swallow bird caws really a
first look even even at the end of my
salad I always drank the rest of the
vinegar in the bowl I love that [ __ ]
love it if it makes your nose run and it
makes you hot is good for you you know
if it makes your body start activating
it's good you're sweating your lows is
running you're all [ __ ] and you're
crazy in your chair well let's have tea
did that to you [ __ ] so it's funny I go
let's go Nutella cochinita I wash my
[ __ ] and we got the clap took it down
el coche chinito and we bet Duncan oh
yeah my buddy Duncan Duncan Ross Russ
and I talked about the comedy stole a
bunch of [ __ ] and then I or did I go let
me call the I can only take two heads
off and gently and I'm gonna want to
there's only a you tell him to get
hungry yeah I go just take to Hitler you
know why you study then okay so I called
my mom ten minutes away came down again
[ __ ] a sleeping pill and I can box of
this thing but whatever you go to a
Cuban restaurant the last thing on the
menus gonna be okay so voila no it's
gonna be a trophy to official something
for a special special values fried
special that means it sports franchises
rice all special special Chinese rice no
pork ham Oh
chorizo Oh [ __ ] amazing it's like a
piñata
it's really dark mmm it's really pungent
spicy a little bit so they put fried
[ __ ] on her that put honest but the
Maduro yeah holy [ __ ] i know i go lead
take the sleeping pill don't eat half of
me I got the recipe for that I eat half
of it listen I was I had 103 fever one
time at a hotel room after I did three
eight walls in a week those weeks where
you get the floor your body breaks down
right there was two feet of snow and I
had a walk to a shop right with [ __ ]
sneakers on I was gonna get pneumonia
haunting and pneumonia
no I didn't was I smoked dope and I went
in the shower I can go in the shower I
made the Latina British steel where you
get the lemon tea yeah shot of whiskey
rye rye and lemon and honey and I drank
that [ __ ] and you bundle yourself up
yeah the bronchitis he has multiplies in
between if he goes to the gym
and he comes out in the wind it's his
back the worst that's when you're in
trouble
that's why am I got six weeks I was in
New York that's a six week four days in
New York with one degree temperature and
I came home and that's when I found that
I had pneumonia two years ago and almost
killed me a month in the hospital
surgery inside of my chest they took
mine out scraped it off [ __ ] horrible
but I thought I just had bronchitis I
kept working and hanging them hustling I
was I'm gonna show taping a show and
I'll come home
Papa's annex drink nangka like was a
[ __ ] soda and knock out that doctor
said if you did that a couple more
nights I don't know if you make it to
the hospital because my kidneys were
shutting down cuz I take a blood
pressure pill on a cholesterol pill but
the over-the-counter meds like nyquil
and contracts that's not good feel good
I didn't know do some dumb [ __ ] dumb
if you take your blood pressure pill
don't do it okay then you're fine you're
too young yet but boom and then you
gotta be really careful I was dehydrated
with the sleep apnea machine I always
have a gallon of [ __ ] water after me
and even though I'm wall over 50 so we
p8 time ah they say either pee at once
sometimes I don't drink water for so
long my ankles start to hurt and my skin
being so dry when I would
a few weeks ago no a so [ __ ] dry
maybe cuz you're up there maybe yeah
yeah altitude sure the altitude [ __ ]
killed me what time I stopped taking my
blood pressure pill I got lazy I said
well the pharmacy tomorrow it turned
into like nine days that I hadn't taken
it like five years ago and I started
touching my shin for some reason and it
was like if like my shin was like like
there was water in there cuz I pressed
my finger they'd leave a dent my god
that's not my body I call it the the
pharmacist he's great he I said that
this thing goes once you stop taking a
pill I said like a week ago I lied he
goes get the [ __ ] down here now you
can't stop taking those pills you'll
fall down you're not getting up yes so
he said that's a Deema you get you're
filling up with water it goes up you
know it went away day and a half but
it's a lot of learning I'm getting to
the age now where you go that's not good
so if you start getting the Dean what do
you and they be diuretic you need to
pill with a diuretic so you pee a lot of
liquid out my blood pressure pill is a
natural diuretic to begin with so I'm up
five times a night
they say you're up once for every decade
you're alive I get up to I used to get
up three times a night and I ordered
this thing beyond raw what's that GNC oh
yeah and it's got like a bunch of stuff
in it so if you work out you take that
it gives you extra protein and show you
now before I go to bed night do sleep so
I 75 before I have to pee
that's good five in a row before you pee
and then one time then I get another -
I'm tip-top Magoo top Magoo once you get
the [ __ ] - hold on the [ __ ] peeps
here always in the house gray-smith
Steve Magee Juan Carlos Maurizio della
pietà Nuno Souza Giggy mick sauce crazy
flips
Jersey made New Jersey my brother and my
man Steve come me so you bad
[ __ ]
thank you don't forget [ __ ]
tomorrow night Columbus Ohio it sold out
already you [ __ ] up I'm not adding
those shows I'm an old man
tired a little something go there my
steez to go and don't forget Mather and
I'll be at the improv so may 5th sink or
the mild smell that fart now it's good
its Gimenez like free to smells like ice
ievo from the greenhouse juice house on
Lankershim I went there for breakfast I
wanted to clean out my system had a nice
uh uh antioxidant bowl which is cherry
extract a little acai some [ __ ]
vanilla a few bananas and they grind it
up calm then they put a little granola
they put some would you [ __ ] berries
help and put some coconut nice [ __ ]
delicious you it's called the greenhouse
nursery dog let me tell you something I
think it's gonna greenhouse you and you
drink a little computer they have
caption around hundreds a little
sousaphone all the grape the ginger ale
the cherry yeah you can't shine bro you
drink that that cleans your stomach out
okay
nicey-nice saying I still see what you
think you do enjoy your bad [ __ ]
advice you go to the green I tell them
uncle Joey sent you take great [ __ ]
people they're half water Rican I love
them half the people work there be oz so
he going to yell Bodie
Wow yeah and they'll give you a free
[ __ ] straw don't forget I'm also at
the Tempe improv the third to the fifth
what else is going on your world pop I
talked to Lisa tomorrow you know what -
no I'm looking for a reason because
tomorrow night's the 18th I'm gonna be
doing a kiss-off podcast I'm gonna sell
and sign some books at rocking rallies
on Sunset Boulevard in West Hollywood
meet-and-greet sell some books you know
I haven't done anything on the road my
podcast yet so this will be the first
time meet some people and we'll see what
happens good for you hey you gotta get
out there you gotta get home you know
it's so weird how it's a different time
now let's say right now you had your
show on E
you guys show lasted six years and on
top of that you did a podcast on hey
Tommy
I'm fine now the show ends yeah you know
that knows you still carry that Network
the same brain thought right so it's
such a different mentality now and with
the podcast world that you can retain if
Seinfeld or the world what saying that
little guy that the bald head Jason
Alexander if he would had Facebook on
the way out of Seinfeld you retain all
those fans or you Dell and all those
people me I don't we don't have fancy at
the church we're [ __ ] family
ain't no church no family the same
[ __ ] our [ __ ] right we'll the church
will [ __ ] solid family we help each
other out when we can you know I try to
go to the message board and [ __ ] around
with people that deke sigh at and my
other brother running what's his name
again it's not coming yet Scott [ __ ]
Cunningham I got so I could remember
you're very active I see you always
talking to people online on social media
I love your little social medias yeah I
love it there's a lot of people comment
you're [ __ ] weird no I'm not getting
going
I now he cares people right loss on the
webpage
they know that I've gone through a loss
yeah and I want to condone some you know
I want to let them know I'm there
they're [ __ ] in their formats
listen this is not I don't want you to
be one of those people that listen to 20
podcast now no I want you to watch this
grow I want to be there when you suck
and I want to be there when you're good
the Yankees are never always good right
some years they suck that's why I
respect the guy like Nick for to roll
I'm on forever because these guys are
Yankee fans yeah they don't buy anything
at the week oh [ __ ] that not the [ __ ]
thing you know I got Bob Lowe Lingus and
Bobby Sheeran and look at who I was with
last night Garnett came to the [ __ ]
comedy show I took a picture with him
but I got a hat on I look like I'm too
fat he's guys whatever from Canada you
know that would Tripoli and stuff like
this I'm very [ __ ] kid you know we
have certain you can't run a quick one
on this now we know who's been here
since they [ __ ] won from cleaner than
anyone spooky
we know Leon we know halfway crap what's
my little young brother up there doing
chicken people up [ __ ] up there the 18
year old kid
oh and a fourth wall no the [ __ ] kid
up in Cassius Morris supposed to be on
already but once I get that I'm gonna
know who's been this is day one so I
wanna appreciate you guys for always
kissing and do me a favor
your Vega AJ Benza tried a mentee a lot
of knowledge he knows gossip he knows
who the dick is getting sucked before
you eat AJ Benza if somebody's dick is
getting sucked in there's a wire and
used to be mine now I know who gets the
[ __ ] email so Tommy's cousins getting
his dick sucked I'll be Judy is back in
town and [ __ ] you know approach truck
Trump story they're the that story just
hit and yeah maybe has a love child I
broke that last Sunday on my show it
came out in the newspapers Thursday I
broke that a week and a half ago I know
I know the chicks name no one knows Judy
Cintron oh Jesus yeah don't worry about
there you go oh that's funny I see these
please waffle Oh with this father be
congested this is a hot box see this
still as if right through your [ __ ]
nose I'm in the middle of us tremendous
is shamash unit I'm happy you came out I
love being around the corner yeah the
studio where you tape is next in my nice
place
oh that's the place you go yeah came in
talking about okay this guy knows coffee
there every Sunday
Joe's the man again will we tie with him
and then three doors down the green
house and the pay you know solid that
pizza place isn't bad either
which one mama no love told me no no no
listen for a big pie for listen no no
I'm not talking about baby why are we
doing this
it comes what no it can't be no not
mamas yes yes how'd you see it please
and then I gotta tell you I'm a [ __ ]
Ron's pizza to Tony's we time you go
with this smells like armpit dog don't
go in there no more please
only my wife instead of getting the
[ __ ] ball up
don't go with the hill I'll tell you why
I'm gonna talk about I won't I won't the
alternative was on Fridays the kids
wanted pizza and my kids don't know from
New York Pizza they've been to John's
they want some dough so that yeah it's
great Papa John's what do you I go Papa
John's is good and I hear go how could
you order that [ __ ] good let's go let's
go the pizzeria find a good pizza place
Danielle's on Laurel Canyon yeah
all right Laurel but I'm on KO'ing and
Magnolia but I'll take a rotten peaches
any nice nice and you get Danielle sage
don't make them make it they're the best
places large fun you've gotta get much
fun the old school that's a good old
that's a good then he sold then he
opened up two of them yeah and he got
greedy the problem with that place
suppose it was too much drama together
slice oh my god I gotta say four holes
just a sheet to pay there she puts in
the window as I see it you gotta pull it
up and it's just something you gotta sit
and wait for the slice that's not what
the slice is a slice boom here's a
dollar throw it in you take my money
then you take it out and give it to me
all you were [ __ ] of you can oil drip
it on already if your fingers got AIDS I
like my [ __ ] slice [ __ ] that's
why it's nothing better than walking
down a New York City Street with a slice
of peach and oil going down your wrist
AJ Benza you're a [ __ ] trip you know
that anyway listen to me are you hiring
posting your position the job sites and
waiting and waiting for the right people
to see it what are the chances you know
I'm saying
listen zip recruiter no I suppose if
there's a smarter way so they built a
platform that finds the right job
candidates for you these invitations
these invitations have revolutionized
how you find your next hire in fact 80%
of employers who post a job on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day that's
one day zipper could have learned what
you're looking for and identifies people
with the right experience and invites
them to apply to your job and the right
candidates are out there and zip
recruiter is how you find them but
listen it doesn't stop there
they even spotlight the strongness
application she received so you'll never
miss a great match
listen businesses of all sizes you zip
recruiter you're in a pinch
right now do me a favor the church
family can
try zip recruiter for free that's right
I said free what'll I stutter free
that's it just go to zip recruiter calm
slash Church that zip recruiter calm
slash Church you know why because zip
recruiter is the smartest way to hire go
to zip recruiter comm slash Church the
best way to hire someone
don't forget Columbus is sold out
tomorrow night so annoying bother what
may 3rd through the [ __ ] 5th talk
about that Tempe Arizona all [ __ ] we're
coming in deep with the Agostino it's
[ __ ] in three days of [ __ ] bedlam
you understand me so I'll see you
[ __ ] in Tempe and don't forget to
keep the [ __ ] struggle we're going
down deep [ __ ] again I want to
thank my man AJ Ben's anytime and I want
to thank my little brother Lisa and I
want to thank you guys for being family
every week thank you very much for
listening to have a great weekend
beautiful